this since the outbreak began more than
38,000 across the country in some places
it's worse right now than it's ever been
the three most populous states that's
California Texas and Florida all broke
their own records for the most cases
reported in a single day think about
that for a second and the CDC predicts
nearly 30,000 more Americans could die
by mid-july Manuel Bojorquez is in
Homestead Florida Manny how was Florida
handling this spike it's not good it is
not good Gale good morning several state
and local jurisdictions are pushing
ahead with mandatory masks orders and
enforcement of social distancing rules
Hospital capacity is also a concern
Holmes that hospital behind me reached
capacity on Tuesday officials say some
beds have now opened up again but
hospitals across the area are prepared
to add additional units if necessary I
think we had it on the ropes you know
it's dr. Sergio Segura is the chief
medical officer of Miami's Baptist
Hospital he says he's seen a significant
increase of coronavirus patients in the
last few days mostly walk-in cases these
are community acquired infections as
opposed to nursing homes Florida was one
of five states reporting record high
increases in coronavirus cases on
Wednesday another was California where
more than 7,000 people tested positive
rises in hospitalizations and rates of
infection prompted governor Gavin Newsom
to warn that a rollback of the state's
reopening is not out of the question as
cases rise in the south and west
the one-time epicenter of the outbreak
is taking precautions people coming in
from states that have a high infection
rate must quarantine for 14 days the
governors of New York Connecticut and
New Jersey warned those in violation of
the rule would face a fine of up to ten
thousand dollars their list of states
includes Texas there is a massive
outbreak of Coppa 19 across the state of
Texas governor Greg Abbott said certain
parts
his state could face new restrictions
after seeing more than 10,000 new cases
in two days the situations in the
hospitals continues to worsen in Houston
hospitals are at 97% capacity and
statewide hospitalizations rose 57% in
the last week several states including
Texas are reporting large increases in
cases among young people as bars and
restaurants reopen I understood the
chance I was taking going out and
obviously now I'm paying that price 21
year-old Adrianna Carter says she and
her friends caught the virus after a
night out in San Marcos Texas she says
while she was being careful many others
were not normal and I hadn't gone out
since the bars reopened it just so
happened that the one night out I did
okay like I did contract coronavirus and
another reminder that the young are
still very much at risk from this
disease 17 year old Carson Davis a high
school student in Fort Myers Florida was
airlifted to a hospital Monday and
passed away the very next day from
complications of kovat 19 Anthony well
bulwark as many thank you